I'm sure all of you know about the Nile
River it is disputedly the longest river
in the world and has been the lifeline
for growth and development across
Northeast Africa the country that is by
far the most dependent on the Nile is
Egypt where 95 of the country's 102
million people live along the Riverbanks
in fact Egypt's population is so
concentrated along the Nile that only
about four percent of the country's land
is actually used by people the
unforgiving deserts that surround the
Nile have only exacerbated this
situation considering this I don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that
protecting the Nile is the top priority
for Egypt over the past Century they've
signed it dozens of treaties and struck
numerous deals to take down any project
that threatens the Egypt's use of the
Nile but one project that they were not
able to stop is the grand Ethiopian
Renaissance Dam also known as the gerd
Dam the goal of the gerd dam was to
capture the mighty of the Nile River to
produce enormous amounts of
hydroelectric power in fact the dam was
projected to provide 65 million
Ethiopians with affordable electricity
this electricity can then be used to
develop Utopia Service Industrial and
agricultural sectors and lift millions
of Ethiopians out of poverty but wait a
minute that sounds like a good thing how
could such a wholesome project be a
negative well the truth is that it's not
a negative at least not for Ethiopia but
the cmf cannot be said about Egypt you
see it the now River does not flow from
north to south as you might intuitively
expect the now River actually flows
South to the north starting in Lake
Victoria located in modern-day Uganda
Tanzania and Kenya and emptying it into
the Mediterranean Sea this means that
Egypt actually gets the tail end of the
river and that any operations Upstream
can affect how much water it needs
thieves and as you probably already
guessed the goddammit is one such
project so here's the story of the dam
that's threatening to end Egypt
taking a look back while the gerd Dam
didn't become a Hot Topic till the 2010s
the project has actually been discussed
for nearly 70 years in fact the U.S
Bureau of Reclamation Act identified the
sight of the Guard dam is somewhere
between 1956 and 1964. but work on the
damn it never got started due to a slew
of political issues first of all
Ethiopia was under the controller of an
emperor named Haile Selassie Selassie
was a controversial leader who had both
good and bad intentions on one side he
introduced the country's first written
constitution in abolished slavery and he
tried to defend Ethiopia from an Italian
invasion though he was unsuccessful at
doing so on the other side however he
was also known for ruling with an Iron
Fist and that doing whatever it took to
keep control for example he was known
for suppressing rebellions and pushing
the boundaries when it came to Human
Rights and let's just say there were a
lot of rebellions especially from the
princes of Ethiopia often referred to as
the mass effect the Mass Effect felt
that selassie's reforms were simply not
good enough and that Ethiopia could be
modernizing way faster if they were in
control ironically if they simply shut
up Ethiopia might have modernized faster
because Selassie was spending a
significant amount of time just keeping
the mass effect in check this issue just
became worse with time as the rebellions
would eventually boil over and become a
military coup that resulted in Selassie
being assassinated in August of 1975.
that wasn't the end of it either it was
actually just the beginning of a 17
year-long Civil War that would take
Ethiopia into the 1990s with all this
drama going on building a dam simply
wasn't the top priority for anyone
establishing stability and peace was a
far greater concern unfortunately
Ethiopia would eventually reach some
level of this by the turn of the century
at this point they could finally start
investing into the country and try to to
turn things around for the better the
gerdamma was of course one of these
initiatives building the dam was by no
means a fast process though the
Ethiopian government started off by
surveying the land between October of
2009 and August of 2010 and the design
of the dam would be finalized a few
months later with initial planning out
of the way the Ethiopian government
would award an Italian company named
Cellini in pregolo now known as rebuild
with the contract to build a dam the
contract was worth 4.8 billion dollars
and this was by no means any easy amount
to put together for perspective when
this dam was approved the cost was over
10 percent of the country's GDP so
funding the dam was very much a national
effort for a full decade the country
sold bonds to their citizens and the
persuaded employees to contribute a
portion of their paycheck to the dam
Ethiopia also received an international
hub from China and some Gulf countries
construction of the dam is actually
still underway and it's not expected to
be completed till 2023 but most of the
dam has been completed and Ethiopia
started filling it up in July of 2020
with just when the controversy reached
New Heights
from Ethiopia's perspective the
goddammit is not only a development
project or an infrastructure project the
gerd dam is a natural right here's the
thing and it's not like Ethiopia is
crossing it into Egypt's border and
directly stealing their water in fact
Ethiopia doesn't even share a border
with Egypt they're actually separated by
Sudan not to mention it the Blue Nile
literally originates from Lake Tana
which is located in Ethiopia so it makes
no sense to Ethiopia that Egypt is
trying to tell them what they can and
they cannot do with their own natural
resources that would be like Abu Dhabi
Italian Saudi Arabia to chill out on the
old production so that they can keep all
prices high if anything Egypt should
only have the power to put in a polite
request that Ethiopia consider how the
dam would affect nearby countries and
their people but even if Egypt was being
polite about it instead of trying to
control the situation it's not like
Ethiopia Opia has another option it's
not like they're building a vanity
project like the Burj Khalifa or the
Jetta Tower if this was the case Egypt
could argue that the welfare of
Egyptians is more important than the
frivolous luxury of Ethiopians but this
is not the case Ethiopia is building the
gurd gamma out of desperate need
Ethiopia is one of the poorest countries
in the world coming in at rank 170 when
it comes to GDP per capita and that's
with the dam before the damn project
Ethiopia's GDP per capita was literally
a hundred and twenty dollars now it's
not like Egypt is killing it and is a
developed country but Egypt has arguably
done far better than Ethiopia their
current GDP per capita stands at 3 500
with just nearly four times Ethiopia so
when Ethiopia is given a choice between
ethiopian's welfare and the Egyptian
welfare the choice is obvious it's not
even a question which country it is in a
more desperate State literally over 90
percent of Ethiopians have been living
in an abject poverty for decades so it's
about time that this finally changes we
should also note that Ethiopia has been
as cautious as possible every step of
the way after all their goal is not to
screw over Egypt their goal is to Simply
Advance their own country and they're
more than willing to try to minimize the
damages to other countries a perfect
example of this is their approach when
it comes to filling up the dam itself
Ethiopia has carefully time to each
villain to take advantage of the chiram
Season which takes place between June
and September this is when rainfall is
at its peak meaning that Ethiopia can
fill up your damn with the minimal
amount of damage not to mention it
Ethiopia is spreading out the fields
between four and seven years so there's
little doubt that Ethiopia is
approaching the dam as slowly and as
methodologically as possible really the
only way Ethiopia could be more careful
is to just not do the project which is
obviously not something that they're
willing to do
hearing Ethiopia's perspective it may
seem like Egypt has a hard case to
defend but it's not that simple from
Egypt's perspective they have literally
given up everything to defend denial and
this doesn't just apply to the gerd Dam
Egypt has defended the Nile for
centuries and they have sacrificed so
much for the river not to mention and
they literally have legal rights to
oversee it and influence Upstream
activities this legal right was agreed
upon way back in 1929 when the now
Waters agreement was signed by Egypt and
Great Britain at the time Great Britain
represented Uganda Kenya Tanzania and
Sudan this treaty however did not
include Ethiopia in fact Ethiopia really
wasn't even considered so while Egypt
does have the legal right to vetoa
Upstream now projects Ethiopia argues
that this right only extends the
countries are involved in the treaty why
should Ethiopia abide by a treaty that
they were weren't even involved in this
wasn't the only treaty that Ethiopia was
left out of either in 1959 Egypt and
Sudan formed an agreement to split the
now water Egypt had rights to 55.5
billion cubic meters of now water and
Sudan had rights to 18.5 billion cubic
meters of now water so once again from
Egypt's perspective they literally have
the legal right to X cubic meters of
water and when Ethiopia's activities
threatened that Supply they feel that
they have the right to fight against
Ethiopia at the same time though
Ethiopia wasn't involved in this
discussion either so why should they
follow this treaty Ethiopia can only
plot that we weren't even involved card
on these two agreements though because
they were very much involved in the
Cairo cooperation framework of July
1993. this was an agreement directly
between Egypt and Ethiopia in this
agreement both countries pledged not to
implement water projects harmful to the
interests of the other and consoled over
projects to reduce waste and increase
the flow of waters while Ethiopia had
deniability with the other agreements
this one is as clear as day Ethiopia
literally agreed to make decisions
together with Egypt but when it came to
the guard dammit it seems like they took
a solo approach I think you can start to
see why Egypt thinks that Ethiopia is in
the wrong also Egypt doesn't just have a
legal basis against Ethiopia but also a
humanitarian one while Egypt is more
well-off than Ethiopia economically this
doesn't mean that they're in a position
where they can negotiate on the Nile 97
of Egypt's fresh water comes from the
Nile and the Nile's water flow has
already been on a decline over the past
several decades combined this with
Egypt's rapidly growing population and
you're left in the position where Egypt
is facing an annual water deficit of a 7
billion cubic meters at the current
deficit Egypt could run out of water by
2025. considering this who actually has
the greater natural right to the Nile is
it Ethiopia where much of the water
originates or is it Egypt where much of
the water is actually used
the fight between Ethiopia and Egypt is
still very much an ongoing situation and
is extremely fluid by the time the gerd
dam is filled up some studies suggest
that the now's fresh water flow to Egypt
may be reduced by 25 percent
Additionally the electricity produced by
Egyptian dams may be reduced by
one-third this would likely take a
massive Tola on the agriculture that
takes place around the Nile which
accounts for 60 percent of Egypt's food
on the other hand the guard Dam has
already started paying off for Ethiopia
despite not even being complete I mean
just take a look at Ethiopia's GDP over
the past 10 years the dam was of course
not the only project contributing to
this rise but it definitely played a
major role given that the girl Dam will
become the largest hydropower facility
in Africa once completed Ethiopia likely
has a lot more benefits to reap from the
gerd Dam but that's only if the rest of
it is fulfilled who do you think is in
the right Egypt or Ethiopia comment that
down below also drop a like if you hope
that both countries are able to sort
this out before the situation becomes
irreversible and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions are logically
answered but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one